[Música]
ahora demos un vistazo a la economía la
jornada del día estuvo marcada por esa
decisión de la última reunión de la
reserva federal de eeuu los detalles los
tiene jorge hurtado aquí en el estudio
de france 24 jorge buenas noches buenas
noches santiago bien que la mayoría de
los funcionarios de la fed esperan que
la política monetaria siga
endureciéndose en ese país según el acta
se esperan aumentos de medio punto para
las próximas reuniones los banqueros
proponen que acelerar estos aumentos los
dejaría bien parados para finales de año
y esto podría alguna forma flexibilizar
al mediano plazo la fed busca controlar
la inflación más alta en 40 años sin que
la economía entre en una recesión
estas subidas han generado gran
volatilidad en los mercados bursátiles
con ventas masivas de acciones índices
como la standard and poor's 500 ha caído
hasta 17 por ciento en lo que va del año
las actas también mostraron que los
encargados de la política monetaria
esperan más aumentos de los precios para
este año
hablemos ahora de rusia jorge porque el
presidente vladimir putin
ordenó el aumento del salario mínimo y
también de las pensiones que es un tema
álgido con los rusos utin reconoce que
este año va a ser bastante difícil sobre
todo para los rusos por la inflación y
las sanciones de que el presidente
aumento ahora
aumentar hasta en 10% el salario mínimo
y las pensiones aunque según él esto no
significa que las dificultades están
relacionadas con la guerra en ucrania
algo que él denomina la operación
militar especial putin también propuso
aumentar los pagos a los soldados que
combaten en la campaña militar en
ucrania aunque no detalló cifras en
abril pasado la inflación en rusia
interanual alcanzó un récord del 17,8
por ciento la más alta en 20 años
escuchamos que dejó
mi sueño
las medidas que estamos tomando apoyan
las demandas internas y lo que es
importante la demanda del producto
interno como resultado de la dinámica de
nuestra economía es mucho mejor de lo
que algunos expertos esperaban y esto
significa que se abrirán nuevas
instalaciones de producción aparecerán
nuevos puestos de trabajo el desempleo
no está aumentando gracias a dios creo
que incluso ha disminuido un poco no
cuál es el nivel actual de desempleo 4%
para ser sinceros no hemos previsto sino
que esperábamos un pico de desempleo
pero está disminuyendo
además gates porque en el foro económico
de davos en suiza el tema de la guerra
de ucrania sigue siendo prioridad en la
agenda ahí el ministro de relaciones
exteriores de ucrania pidió a los países
de occidente que acaben con las
exportaciones rusas como respuesta a la
invasión de estos países por parte de
moscú según dijo espera que el mundo no
financie la maquinaria de guerra del
kremlin escuchamos
export
ahora después de tres meses de lucha mi
mensaje sencillo matar las exportaciones
rusas excepto algunos artículos críticos
que occidente necesita el propósito
estratégico debe ser matar las
exportaciones rusas dejar de comprar a
rusia dejar de permitirles ganar dinero
que luego invierten en maquinaria de
guerra que destruye mata viola y tortura
a la gente de ucrania los tipos jorge
son cada vez más las aristas que deja la
guerra en ucrania por ejemplo ya hay una
perspectiva la baja en cuanto a la
producción global precisamente por el
conflicto en ucrania de hecho una
reducción de la mitad así lo refleja el
último estudio del instituto de finanzas
internacionales el estudio cita a los
efectos de la invasión rusa de ucrania
la respuesta de china del proteico y 19
y el endurecimiento de la política
monetaria en eeuu que mencionábamos
antes asimismo el instituto espera que
los flujos de capital hacia los mercados
emergentes se reduzcan en un 42%
respecto al año pasado según ellos el
riesgo de recesión ha aumentado ya que
se espera que el crecimiento real se
estanque el organismo recortó su
previsión de crecimiento al pib mundial
al 2,3 por ciento de 46 por ciento
esperan que el crecimiento para china se
desacelere al 3.5 desde el 51 de la
estimación anterior el crecimiento para
américa latina se prevé en un 2 por
ciento gracias a los altos precios de
las materias primas que de alguna forma
van a beneficiar a algunos países
productores de la región hoy también
hablo david malpass el ex presidente del
banco mundial le aseguro que el alza de
los precios de los alimentos podría
desencadenar en una recesión mundial
porque el corto este panorama ya claro
cómo reaccionar los mercados las
diferentes bolsas en el mundo empecemos
en eeuu las acciones de las principales
empresas fabricantes de armas en ese
país subieron esto después del ataque en
texas que dejó 19 niños y 2 maestras
los inversores prevén un aumento de la
demanda por el temor de posibles
restricciones a la venta de armamento en
europa el selectivo de fráncfort cerró
con una subida del 0,63 por ciento
aunque su índice tecnológico que se
llama tecdax cayó un 0,12 por ciento en
américa latina la bolsa de sao paulo
cerró estable tras una sesión volátil en
la que uno de los grandes perjudicados
fue el sector bancario de ese país
porque muchas gracias por este completo
informe de la actualidad de la economía
de la jornada de hoy ustedes pueden
seguir con nosotros ya viene el debate
[Música]